you know out of here
the premise of the movie gravity is that
space debris hits the International
Space Station it causes utter
destruction which is a little
unrealistic but that scenario is
actually what people are scared of
my name is amber yang I am 19 years old
and I am a physics major college student
at Stanford University I'm also the
founder of seer tracking so we take the
data of current satellites and
spacecraft and try to predict if there
will be any collisions with space debris
so space debris is any defunct man-made
space part or spacecraft that is
orbiting in low-earth orbit right now
they can be as small as a paint Fleck to
as big as a completely dead satellite
and they often travel as fast as 17,500
miles per hour and you can only imagine
with something traveling that quickly
that its impact on another orbiting
object will be extremely large and will
cause lots of damage this space debris
could have such a big impact on
essentially the success of the American
space program and mankind's advancement
into space technologies I watched this
series of videos that astronaut scott
kelly published would have to duck into
the Soyuz capsule which is an adjacent
capsule to the International Space
Station because there was fear that the
spacecraft that he was in might be hit
by space debris
we're just inside one minute from the
time of closest approach
it first became like an issue around the
1950s and really in the past few decades
that number has been skyrocketed there
is a concept that as the space debris
collide with other space debris and
other objects that fragmentation will
cause even more space debris to occur
[Music]
currently the method for tracking space
debris is extremely inaccurate at times
because the orbit of space debris
changes so quickly the method that I
have introduced is using artificial
neural networks and artificial
intelligence to track space debris an
artificial neural network is essentially
a computer's version of the human mind
it will provide a prediction it will say
I think this is where the space debris
will be in this future point in time and
if we find the actual point in time in
the future where the space debris is and
there is an error metric between the
artificial neural network and where the
space debris actually is we can tell the
neural network that oh you're wrong by
this amount I am basically allowing the
artificial intelligence to learn the
patterns of how the space debris
positions are changing over time and it
will keep training itself until its
predictions are actually very very
accurate the primary concern would be
for things already orbiting in space and
trying to allow these things orbiting in
space to have enough time to move out of
collisions way if my software predicts
that there would be a future collision
another thing that it could be readily
used for is predicting when is the best
optimal launch time for things like now
it's SpaceX when they're trying to find
a time window where to launch their
rockets and other space cargo they want
to look out a window where there isn't a
lot of space to breathe right now a lot
of people are putting space debris on
the back burner they're saying it could
be potentially very dangerous someday
but right now it's not that big of a
concern because we haven't really had
any casualties yet but the very
terrifying version of the Kessler
syndrome would be a space atmosphere so
trashed that you couldn't launch
anything up without it being hit by
space debris the whole goal is that
we're trying to preserve our earth our
atmosphere for future generations in
front of us and in order to keep
developing technologies that will
succeed and go to space we need to make
sure there is enough space in space to
not have to be hit by space debris
thanks for watching now if you're
interested in what it takes to get into
outer space head over to our sister site
The Verge and watch spacecraft with
Lauren grush check it out and subscribe
for more videos